overturn it but it's a full-time of the
Trump administration and now you've
taken it to the Supreme Court and we
will fight
we will fight of that fight there but
I'm very proud of the work of our
Chairman to bring our agenda for the
people the work of the committee members
second part of our agenda was the was to
lower health care costs bigger paychecks
by building the infrastructure of
America and to do so in a green way for
the future it was a very lengthy bill 25
hours of in the Rules Committee that so
not in the Rules Committee but in the
amendment process and then a long time
on the floor I want to salute they
maestro of it all
Peter DeFazio but many other chairmen
played a role in that and I've
acknowledged them but this is it's a
broad bill it's transformational it's
the biggest and greenest infrastructure
bill in the history of our country and
it's about roads and bridges and surface
transportation for sure it's also about
clean water the some of our water
systems over 100 years old made of brick
and wood and now this will be the source
is there to to change that it's about
infrastructure for broadband so that all
children all families in our country can
have distance learning and telemedicine
and all that that takes whether they
live in rural areas which is a focus on
law or urban deserts in that regard
interestingly Senator McConnell
complains is so-called infrastructure
bill would siphon billions in funding
from actual infrastructure to funnel
into climate change policies exactly
we're not siphoning off money we're
building the infrastructure for the
future not for the 50s and we're doing
it in a way
that cleans there is a health issue
clean air clean water it's an economic
issue transportation transfer product -
from farm to market and the rest it's a
fabulous bill it would take too long to
go further into it but be sure it's the
safest and greenest infrastructure bill
we're proud of this legislation because
you know what it advances environmental
justice in our health care bill it was
about justice in health care addressing
the concerns of previously underserved
communities who are now more drastically
affected by the coronavirus part of it
was again in that regard many of you
there on the steps of the Capitol
rolling out the solving the climate
crisis action plan led by congresswoman
a madam chair Cathy castor of Florida
the most detailed sweeping climate plan
in over a decade reflecting over a
hundred hearings across nearly every
committee in the Congress lower health
care costs bigger paychecks cleaner
government in the cleaner government
piece in the last few days the
centerpiece was the George Floyd justice
in policing Act which will fundamentally
transform the culture of policing of
ending police brutality and bring
accountability to our police departments
it will save lives that recognizes that
overwhelmingly our men and women in
uniform take great pride and the
integrity that they bring to their job
but some don't and this bill addresses
that and we're so proud that George
Floyd's family allowed us to name the
bill for him if they said it met his
their standards that was last Thursday
on last Friday we proudly for the first
time the House voted to
grant statehood to the District of
Columbia are members of Congress again
our priority and even all left decision
safety is our top priority if you're not
if that people aren't safe what what is
the rest of the rest of it doesn't
matter as much a matter of intelligence
force protection is a top priority to
protect our men and women in uniform
before the initiation of hostilities or
in response to them when they are in
danger their protection is of the
highest priority and so when of there
are allegations of threats to our men
and women in uniform we expect the
President of the United States to give
them that same force protection that
same priority and we're disappointed
that that has not happened in the last
Russia I called for Russian sanctions to
be expanded in our last Russian sections
sanctions legislation you may recall we
had a strong bipartisan bill that was to
be sent to the president but the White
House said they want us to take out the
sanctions on Russia that pertained to
the intelligence and the defense sectors
the very sector that is accused of
possible threats on our men and women in
uniform we have to restore those
whatever else happens of this we must
restore all those sanctions and we must
act upon them while we're in an
international arena as many of you know
I saw some of you there this week
Beijing passed its so-called national
security law which signals the death of
the one country two systems' principle
when I say I saw some of you there I'm
the Foreign Affairs Committee hearing
yesterday as one who has worked on human
rights in China in a bipartisan way with
our colleagues across the aisle across
the capital that was so encouraging to
see the room was an overflow crowd of
members from both sides of the aisle of
course we had to keep our distance and
therefore the members some had to sit in
it you know shall we say audience and
others had just to come in virtually but
it was the fullest participation for us
to review what is happening there it was
a proud and broad bipartisan
participation to shine a light and
condemn this law Congress again on a
bipartisan basis in uniting in our
mission to hold Beijing accountable last
year the House passed the Hong Kong
human rights and democracy act and
yesterday we passed Hong Kong autonomy
Act which had already passed the Senate
and that is to helped end
China's campaign of cruelty against Hong
Kong you've heard me say it again and
again if we don't speak out against
violations of human rights in China
because of commercial interest we lose
all moral authority to speak out against
human rights violations any place in the
world getting back to the flag and the
fourth of July we take that pledge every
day in civic arena pledge to the flag
ends with liberty and justice for all
and everything that I talked about here
whether it was health care or job
security or environmental justice or
justice in policing statehood for the
district we're talking about liberty and
justice for all that has to be central
to all of the legislation that we have
put forth and I'm proud to say that it
has been in this array of bills that
came forth between last Thursday and
yesterday evening
and now we'll come back but continue our
work in committee to bring forth
legislation when we come back
central to them all will be liberty and
justice for all especially poignant for
us as we observe the 4th of July my
question that grant on that grants
refugee status to Hong Kong residents do
you support that or there's a bipartisan
bill on that and also what is your
overall reaction to mass arrests during
July first hearing yesterday I had the
privilege by unanimous consent to
participate in the hearing and to listen
to the testimony of the witnesses and I
said they're one of my concerns about
the law was is it starting now that you
cannot you can practically do nothing
you have no expression of anything that
you would not be susceptible to
prosecution probably in Beijing so my
question was does this retroactive does
this apply to all of the of the protests
the Democrats for democratic freedoms
that have happened in Hong Kong I don't
know the answer to that the Chinese
government does and unfortunately
they're not sharing that with us right
now but I fear for it but if you if you
saw the security of so-called national
security what it is is suppression of
any expression in Hong Kong it really
sad so on I'm disappointed obviously in
the arrest of anyone who's speaking out
peacefully for democratic freedoms
wherever it is in terms of refugee I'm
not familiar with that but those people
would qualify because they have by this
law a well-founded fear of persecution
in there
and the place of origin from which they
would come so they would qualify on that
score I would rather we could make it
right in Hong Kong so that that place of
such entrepreneurship and dynamism and
spirit of democracy I told you before
when when therefore 2 million people
were in the street like a year and a
half ago I said to the president could
you say something about the young people
in the street he said did you see the
size of that ground 2 million people I
said young even more significant when
you know that that is 25% of the
population of Hong Kong this is a real
tragedy it's so sad but in the Congress
in the house and in the Senate in a very
unified way we have all worked together
it has been for me a joy to be bonding
with my colleagues on both sides of the
aisle both sides of Capitol on this very
important issue and the Republicans have
been there every step of the way I hope
the president will be having nothing to
do with the briefing that we had today
I think the president should have been
verbally braced on it but I thought that
before the hearing and has nothing to do
with anything that we were presented at
the hearing of course the president
should have been briefed this is above
the highest priority fourth protection a
threat to our men and women in uniform
the president it was in his PDB
presidential Daily Brief but he wasn't
verbally but that doesn't mean that he
shouldn't have read that but again
having nothing to do what we saw today
didn't know about this I do know that I
will say this it was of a consequential
level that the intelligence community
should have brought it to us in that way
but what is important is the president's
relationship with Russia this is this is
at the same time as the White House was
aware of this threat to the security of
our men and women in uniform the
president was still flirting with the
idea of having Russia be part of the g8
in total opposition to the wishes of the
other members of the g8
he wasn't they weren't there Russia
wasn't because of their annexation of
Crimea their invasion of Ukraine you
can't be in the g8 or g7 so why was the
president why were they not raising this
to a level of the state of the president
this is not a good time for you to be
saying Russia should be part of the g8
when in fact there is reason to suspect
that Russia was um was threatening the
security of our men and women in uniform
so to that end what should happen now
you mentioned potentially restoring
those sanctions I know you just had this
briefing but do you think there are
other steps that Congress should take in
light of everything we're learning about
this episode well let me just say Garet
reference my statement about I said it
earlier I think that they that when
Congress in a bipartisan way passed
sanctions on Russia the administration
told us to take out the sanctions on the
grq the intelligence as well as the
defense sectors of Russia those should
definitely still be they were there in a
bipartisan way it's just the
administration wanted them out I don't
know why so we should have those in
there in any event as its proceeds we'll
see what other sanctions are there
should be but we want to move all doubt
in anyone's mind
that just because it's Russia I'm just
because all roads for president leads to
Putin doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
taking careful guard of our elections
because 24/7 they are trying to
undermine the integrity of our elections
again and other concerns that we have
about Russian behavior and cybersecurity
and in actually security issues but we
don't subject it to the same kind of
scrutiny this administration doesn't
because it's Russia yes sir on the
domestic front you're leaving now for a
few weeks you come back July 20th is
there enough time to negotiate a
compromise on a so the next Cove in
relief package yep I'm not leaving for
two weeks so don't give my husband my
husband and my family and he thought
that I will be there for two weeks
no we come back to the beginning of next
week with the appropriations committee
starting actually on Monday for some
subcommittees my understanding for sure
Tuesday so that they can put the
subcommittee can do their work on
Appropriations and then the full
committee and we capture can do their
each of those bills so that when we do
come back we're ready to go to the floor
many people will be here some happy
virtual some of it hybrid some of it
actual some of the virtual will see but
Congress will be intensely working not
just not just Appropriations Committee
but that is what must be done by
September 30th so that has a priority
and last night they didn't go too late
they were a reasonable time the defense
bill was passing them the NDA the
National Defense Authorization Act fifty
six to zero completely bipartisan bill
we were very proud of that but yes now
we have we know we have every
thing we haven't in the heros act is
something the Republicans have voted for
before except one thing which is a
stronger OSHA standard to protect our
workers but everything else in the bill
they voted for before so this is nothing
new to them some of it bigger some of it
fresher but all of it something they
voted on before and we're having how
this works is the committee's do their
work and then what is unresolved gets
kicked up to the four leaders and what's
unresolved there obviously the president
is going to sign the bill would weigh in
there so they know they they made their
overtures they also have said publicly
that this err that should be in the next
bill so we anticipate we will have a
bill yes sir speaker back if I may to
the intelligence the White House
continues to say that this is not yet
verified one of the reasons that the
president it did not rise to his level
it sounds like you're speaking about
this may being a little bit more
conclusive than the White House believes
that it is is that your view let me just
say this
you got the Conn the White House put on
a con that if you don't have a hundred
percent consensus on intelligence that
you shouldn't be it shouldn't rise to a
certain level well we would practically
be investigating nothing if you had to
start on a hundred percent so don't buy
into that and neither should the in does
the intelligence community it's it's an
investigate it's gathering intelligence
and they have enough intelligence to
know where we have to go next with it so
I don't I don't know what the point of
your question is that just because they
didn't have 100% of consensus should
this be not briefs to the President of
the United States when it involves the
security and safety of our men and women
in uniform as we said in our statement
Chuck Schumer and he should spend more
time reading the daily presidential
briefs the presidential Daily Brief over
than planning military parades and
preserving the relics of the Confederacy
I'm not you obviously care a lot about
symbols and symbols of America I think
there can you update us on where you
think things stand with the Confederate
statues remaining in the Capitol and if
you just assume that now that's left to
the states because leader McConnell is
not engaging and also vice-president for
Vice President Biden said this week he
believes there's a distinction for
Jefferson Washington both of those men
there's a bust of Washington and a
statue of Jefferson in the house side
which you control do you believe there's
a distinction or should there be a
conversation about those representations
as well I do believe that if people have
committed treason against the United
States of America their statues should
not be in the Capitol and that is and we
took down the paintings of the speakers
who were members of the Confederacy and
there will be legislation coming forth
to remove those same people who meet
that low description if you've committed
treason against the United States of
America
it's not about Washington and Jefferson
it's about Alexander Stephens read what
he said about people it's about the
president of the Confederacy whose
statue is up there who committed treason
against the United States so that's the
clarity that we should have some of it
is the states have put them there the
states may want to review but in the
meantime while they may be in this
Capitol we can decide where they are in
the Capitol thank you very much happy
fourth of July
take care of keep a distance wash your
hands happy fourth thank you